hey 42 here on average 12 newborns will
be given to the wrong parents daily
welcome to RIF the limbo world record is
just six inches high one in every four
Americans has appeared on TV Johnny
Cash's estate was approached by an
advertising company asking for
permission to use Ring of Fire on an ad
for hemorrhoid cream the request was
refused in the Durango desert in Mexico
there's a creepy spot called the zone of
silence you can't pick up any clear TV
or radio signals and locals sometimes
say that fireballs appear in the sky
every year about 98% of the atoms in
your body are replaced as a punishment
for misbehavior Thai cops have to wear
pink Hello Kitty armbands if the
population of China walked past you in
single file the line would never end
because of their rate of reproduction
the Bible is the number one most shock
lifted book of all time breathing the
air in Mumbai India for just one day is
equivalent to smoking 2.5 packs of
cigarettes and finally there are more
plastic flamingos in the United States
than real ones thanks for the view
subscribe for more 42
you